anytime you don't have to ask permission
is awesome and now you don't I grew up
on comic books my father taught me to
read with comic books when I was a
little kid spider-man the Hulk or on TV
it's always been a part of how I see the
world Jason McNamara is an award-winning
graphic novelist based in Northern
California he's been creating and
publishing comics for the better part of
a decade but when it came time to issue
his latest creation Jason decided to
bypass the traditional publishing route
largely controlled by diamond comic
distributors and go online instead so
the Rattler is a book that I wrote
co-created with Greg Hinkle was an
artist in LA and we spent a long time on
the book it wasn't convinced that going
with a publisher or going with diamond
was the best first step for the book I
thought we could get more attention and
awareness of the project if we did a
very public Kickstarter part of what i
like about Kickstarter is that you're
selling the story of its creation you're
not just selling the book Jason is just
one of the many in the comics community
that's embracing digital platforms like
Kickstarter and comiXology to finance
and publish their projects the emergence
of these digital platforms has provided
a more diverse selection of comics for
fans by allowing creators to break
through editorial gatekeepers and
produce content without sacrificing
artistic integrity or ownership Matt
sylheti chair of the comics program at
california college of the arts describes
the traditional publishing process
traditionally publishers were sort of a
the gatekeepers of comics and that's not
necessarily a terrible thing I mean
there's an editorial I that sort of
curates the stuff that gets out into
bookshelves but other than that you
basically were folding and stapling
comics by yourselves and trying to hand
sell them at shows maybe a publisher
took a look at your stuff and decided
they want to collect it but most of the
cartoonists and comics writers that I
know had to do it themselves though most
comic creators do a bulk of publishing
work themselves they need a distributor
to get their books onto shelves and into
the hands of customers let's say that
you've got a great book
you even had the funds to do a print run
yourself there's still the hurdle of
getting your books in the comic shops in
order to get in the comic shop so you
had to go through diamond they do have a
monopoly on sort of the comics community
and diamond does a lot of great things
for retailing but they also have a
business model that requires you to have
a certain number of pre-orders for you
even to be sort of considered as part of
the catalog and if you're not in that
catalog nobody's seeing your work but
now you have these emerging platforms
like comiXology which has a lower
barrier of entry they accept more books
so diamond will turn a lot of stuff down
based on whether they think it's worth
it to them if its content you know you
have to appeal to their taste on what
they think the comiXology is more open
so why ask permission you don't have to
ask permission you can just do it
instead of asking a publisher for
permission Jason turned to his fans and
launched a Kickstarter to raise funds to
print his own book while he initially
sought forty six hundred dollars in
backing he brought in over three times
his goal so by going through Kickstarter
first we could get a real idea of what
the interest is for this book and I do
think that people that buy books from
Kickstarter are not the same people that
buy books in the store there is an
element of of entrepreneurship and
there's a gamble that appeals to people
in kickstarter I've had better
conversations with people that I've had
over the past ten years of doing
conventions like I can meet them here I
can meet their expectations that I can
engage them in a way I can't at any
other venue as more creators are turning
to online platforms to publish their
work consumers are also reacting to the
digital marketplace favorably comic
sales broke industry records in 2014
with digital comics contributing an
estimated 90 million dollars in sales
the rise of these digital platforms has
only helped to expand readership which
has led to bigger profits in the comics
industry and an increase of brick and
mortar retailers I don't think digital
digital's going to take over but i do
think digital and and the retailers will
strike a balance the books that i buy
now from retailers are usually higher
end products like hundred-dollar artist
collections from idw i don't buy as many
floppy and stuff but i spend more money
and on retailers on higher end stuff
that you can't get in the same digital
experience so what does this all mean
for the future of the comics industry
overall comics is healthier than ever
but if you look at the sort of projects
that are out there in the web comics
world that are now trickling into the
Kickstarter comics world the diversity
is amazing and not just in terms of the
types of projects in the genres but in
terms of the creators and if the book is
good enough it will find an audience and
if it didn't like you learned your
lessons and you'll do something
different next time but you don't have
to make content for them you can make
content for yourself at any time you
don't have to ask permission is awesome
and now you don't so publish it or don't
click the links below to see more and
subscribe to our channel to get all the
latest videos from reason TV